yep me as always still a big fan of two
things Benedict Cumberbatch and Star
Trek now they're together still and
we're gonna talk about it because it's
awesome seriously I love that dude it's
almost man-crush ish at this point just
weird to say but now that I'm throwing
it out there and you I'm just saying you
love the dude to resume a new trailer
for star trek into darkness was on the
Super Bowl there's not a lot new in it's
30 seconds long but there's enough new
to talk about because it's 30 seconds of
bad-ass like how we said it all
creepy cuz it is what it is do you think
your world is safe it is not hell are
you the best part is when Benedict
Cumberbatch is all like Cumberbatch II
which is my way of saying intellectual
badass cuz when Kirk's talking to him
you just you know his business the
funny thing is in the other trailer as
well as this trailer he's all saying oh
you think your world is safe it's not
okay yeah he's after the Federation I
just know that he's a guy who's pissed
off at the Federation but this one
really gives you the feeling that the
world is doomed yeah visit the
Federation I'm gonna burn the planet
earth to the ground what better way to
do that than to make the enterprise
itself fall from space I was gonna say
the sky but it's space and the best part
is when all the ambient noise goes down
and it's just is getting real and
the only noise you get is the Star Trek
he sounds like you know the sound of the
bridge it's all awesome it's all like
shall we begin
I was literally smiling when that sound
was happening I was just like yeah so
the enterprise just eat which is
funny because that was there was a rumor
that it was another enterprise ish
looking ship but it's not actually the
enterprise no pretty sure that's the
enterprise falling from space into Lake
awesome movie that's what it is it's
actually officially dubbed Lake awesome
movie
so in this technological Wonderland this
utopia that we live in where information
is just going everywhere there is
nothing called mystery in movies anymore
because this is all on blogs now this
movies pretty shrouded in secrecy still
don't know much about the villain we
know his name at this point we don't
know much about him all we know is he's
a guy who likes wrecking is really
menacing and is better at everything
apparently to him Weber Cumberbatch is
badass
I don't know how Kirk is dealing with
this cuz he's like god I just
became captain I almost lucked out like
the captain was like hey kid dad your
first officer oh look at that now your
captain I want to talk about falling
into a role it's like Ashley Simpson
wasn't that lucky you remember her
no okay and now he has to go
head-to-head with this guy no thanks not
in a million years well for Earth maybe
right so the star trek into darkness
Super Bowl spot what did you think of it
what do you think of all of this this
being Star Trek II I guess whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more I'm trekking out
of here I'm gonna go on thinking calm
and buy a lot of really useless Star
Trek it's not even a plug that's
actually what I'm gonna go do
you